all right so straight off of rehearsals
filming what were we just doing
straight off from rehearsals i'm winded
i am yeah i'm just i'm excited i'm also
flashing my prototype mic
holster which i shouldn't be doing but
that's a spoiler for
something so okay i love this so what
does it feel like to be here i mean i
think every artist
dreams of walking on the grammy stage at
one point and here you are triple
nominee
performance yikes it's amazing it's
amazing and it's different because what
i've seen
is like not the covet version of it
so this feels very special but um
it's it's still incredible and i feel
blessed okay so after the amas i know
there was a tattoo
to see an award come out again like if
it's the grammys
one my friend has to get a tattoo of my
name
on his my dj from day one
has to get a tattoo right on his
whatever can i say the a word
on his cheek he has to get on his booty
on his booty
and he has to get it on there and prove
it and i'm going i'm gonna see it and
i'm just i'm really excited
if that does happen if we do win
something so he's supposed to get
this my dj yes like nine years okay
he is going to get a tattoo if i win
only if you win nominated yes exactly so
let's clear the air because
the internet thinks he already has it
because you got the knob i've drawn it
okay and what is it's a big grammy it's
your face it's
i think it was like a little circular
head with a big nose
and then like two eyes and then i like a
little tongue i don't know honestly it
could be anything
okay but i'm gonna make sure that he
doesn't go down looking crazy
i was just playing with him but i love
this i love that there's a little wager
so the wager's still
on for grammy weekend yes and what would
it mean for you
to have that grammy and to be awarded by
the academy
i like i don't it's amazing it's an
incredible feeling and i'm just glad
that people enjoy what i'm doing like
that's
why i'm doing this i want to make stuff
that i like and that
other people can enjoy with me so that's
bottom line
i want to talk about the style like what
do you have planned for grammy weekend
because there's a performance there's a
red carpet
i know that you just have been so
influential in this new kind of look
without spoiling it it's a little bit
like this
okay but a lot more sharp and edgy and
interesting
and it's very sexy and it's but it's no
skin no skin at all and that's
it it's giving face and that's it i love
this and talk about working with brett
and how you guys what's your
creative collaboration like working with
brett is a blessing
he's incredible like he he just
he's like a genie like i always say he
can like pull
anything out of my dreams and nightmares
and everything
that i've ever you know thought of so he
nailed this one
like he does with with everything he put
a lampshade on my head one time i'll
never forget
never did you wear it out i wore it in
if that makes sense so here we are and
now we are kind of pushing forward this
has been an incredible album for you
obviously a historic rise
but now we're getting a new album and
now you're probably going to get to do
this one with the tour and go out into
the world so talk to me about
the sound the feel the era everything's
getting better with time when i
say that i mean like when i'm singing
when i'm making music
all of my songs the more recent the
better so me not being able to perform
hot pink it's heartbreaking but yeah
i'm very excited to do this next project
and i'm very excited for kobe to be
over like all of us are let's do it and
i yeah i'm just i can't i can't wait to
do this
and and say this is like the funeral of
say so i feel like
you know i'm i'm in my all black you
know this is i got my team some
sweatsuits and all these are so
cute we need to get those what and turn
it around
boom so cute